I'm good I'm good I did did you yeah no
no what do you mean of course not a
plane oh you did oh got it you didn't
work out slacker
a slacker I'm a slacker wait dude five
years yeah congratulations
five years I know I'm really excited
congratulations that means because I
care get any of the actors say that no
they didn't know my name hello that when
you were on top of him all he could
smell was you come true for Jeffrey yes
well look I have this thing it's been
reported so I'm not you know it's not
like all right this is a big secret but
I every character has a different smell
to it like little different mannerisms
idiosyncrasies and for me everyone has a
different smell so the character for
rampage at a certain smell certain
cologne that Jeffrey apparently liked
you can't blame the guy quick really
quick because it's about George it's
about you and you're George's
relationship sign language what's the
one sign language you've kept with you
you Georgia okay Sharon you're not ready
for this vodka tequila language that you
learned that you came home yeah that was
great I learned sign language for the
movie and you know I spent a lot of time
with Dian Fossey foundation too as well
spend time with gorillas and
primatologists in Atlanta was able to
learn sign language and and you know I
had to sign language consultants one guy
was awesome and the second part of the
story is the director Black Panthers
wife was my sign language yes great
right and that cool so somehow I'm
responsible for the success of Black
Panther oh did you get the gear oh
you'll get it tomorrow oh I'll make sure
okay okay all right I'll see you
tomorrow okay